Welcome to talk to Google.
Ah,
I am very pleased today to welcome and to the and Joe Russo,
directors of the new marvel film,
Captain America Civil War.
Please join me in a massive round of applause and welcoming Anthony and Joe
Russo.
[inaudible]
I am.
I spent good as money yesterday on these actual bobbleheads so hopefully some of
that goes back to you eventually.
Unfortunately you caught it that good.
I'm,
hello gents.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I will kick off by asking,
can you hear me in the women if I don't use the mic?
Yes,
yes.
Okay,
so I mentioned community and [inaudible] at the top.
I saw the movie last week.
It's very good.
Okay,
well I'm mean treated is,
did you glean much from working on those very much ensembles,
TV shows to working on a big ensemble movie?
What do you don't want to TV show that
ensemble work is very important.
I mean,
look,
even at our first movie,
welcome to Collinwood was also at a large ensemble movie.
I mean for whatever reason,
Joe and I are really drawn to ensembles.
I think part of the reason is,
you know,
we're like,
we're film Geeks,
we like movies that you can,
uh,
watch multiple times and kind of geek out on him.
And I think one thing that ensemble storytelling gives you,
it gives you a number of different access points to a story.
And I think you can maybe sort of choose to choose,
choose which character you want to say kind of like side with or access the
story from.
And I think that's part of the fun of ensemble story telling.
But I think also with our shows like community and arrested development,
you know,
those shows we like to play with,
um,
sort of ideas of genre and what your expectations of genre we're and how can we
subvert sort of genre expectations and storytelling.
And that was something that was very,
uh,
very important to us and how we approached the storytelling and civil war.
But,
so this is an audience that hasn't seen the movie,
so we have to remember my question is,
will be free of spoilers.
Okay,
good.
Uh,
so,
and how did you make sure that each character had his moment to shine?
I'm interested in sort of the story boarding process because Marvin is very much
an ensemble piece.
You've got Kevin Fygi who's the kind of overarching producer.
Then you've got the directors and the writers as well.
So how do you work as a team to bring a movie to fruition?
This is,
we,
um,
we sit in a room with Markus and McFeely,
uh,
um,
you know,
a conference room for a month or two.
And we talk about what we want to accomplish with the film,
what,
what teams we want.
This is usually before we decide on what story we're telling themes that we
want,
uh,
um,
we want to say about the characters,
what characters are interested in working with.
And then once we have a story that we're happy with an,
you know,
Kevin comes into the room,
uh,
we talk it through with him.
He,
you know,
he gives us thoughts and,
uh,
um,
particularly on this one,
it was very complicated because we're adding,
um,
uh,
you know,
Tony Stark is the character to the film.
Uh,
Robert Downey was not under contract to do the movie.
it is not insignificant,
uh,
um,
to bring him on board a film like this.
So,
uh,
we had to,
you know,
ask Kevin to,
uh,
to go work his magic and,
and figure out a deal with Robert secondarily once that was accomplished.
I mean,
I think we're incredibly greedy on this project.
We then went and asked him if he could figure out how to get Spiderman from
Sony,
uh,
at which is a,
you know,
a unprecedented deal where you're having to corporations who are competitors
sharing $1 billion piece of Ip,
uh,
with each other.
Uh,
and that was an incredibly complicated deal.
It took many months.
Um,
and,
uh,
and so,
you know,
from a process standpoint,
once we,
once we agree on what we want,
the,
uh,
the story to be a,
we then start layering the script with Markus and McFeely.
They do a draft.
They come back in and,
and we very meticulously go through the script and tracking each character.
So I'll spend two days talking exclusively about Captain America,
then we'll spend a day talking about the Tony Stark arc and then a day talking
about scarlet witch and you know,
making sure that each character has some movement,
no matter how incremental,
uh,
so that they are different at the end of the movie than where they started the
film.
And I think very much at the end of the movie,
it's fair to say a number of the characters on a very different place to where
they started.
And did you,
I mean,
when you told we need to get the character's hair,
or as you're planning through to infinity wars,
is that kind of,
you know,
the Johnny's they're going to take,
I'm intrigued with,
with ant man,
as I said,
I don't want to spoil it,
but you know,
you're playing with someone else's counter.
Yeah.
And so how does that
demystify the process at marvel?
A little bit.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's wide open.
You can tell whatever story you want to tell,
whatever,
whatever.
You know,
Kevin's only agenda is that the,
that the stories are good stories.
Uh,
but there's a,
and he's very good about,
um,
uh,
you know,
each process being very hermetic.
You know,
the,
it's,
it's a very healthy and,
and humble approach,
which is a,
if we don't make this movie the best movie that it can possibly be,
then we might not get another movie.
So it's not,
you're not,
you're not planning too far ahead.
However,
uh,
it is a little bit like United artists over there right now because a lot of the
other directors are very good friends of ours and a,
we're texting each other and emailing each other constantly.
And we're all have a collective goal,
which is to tell the best stories that we can.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so there's a constant dialogue going on.
And,
uh,
Anthony,
just by nature of our relationship are our collaborators.
What's,
what we have to do every day,
talk things out with people.
So we enjoy the,
uh,
the process of engaging other directors is what we did for years as executive
producers and television where we would supervise directors who would come in
and work on the show.
As we engage,
we enjoy that process of engagement,
but it's very wide open.
Uh,
it's about as a,
it's about as healthy as a,
uh,
a studio experiences you can have in the business.
I think that's the secret.
I think that that's part of the secret to their success,
frankly,
is they do,
I mean it
is,
you think it's a,
Oh,
it's unprecedented in the sense that it's serialized storytelling,
but there's a very,
very big discipline about one movie at a time and letting that movie become
whatever it wants to be.
Yeah.
So Infinity Ward's too,
which I did the math I think is the 22nd film,
some something of that plus ATV chosen,
so forth.
So that isn't set in stone now.
There's still a process before we,
before you get there.
Oh,
very much.
Yeah.
We're just in the midst of that process now.
We don't even,
Markus and McFeely are right now working on a,
there are about to turn in the first draft to us.
So we're just at that point of filling both back to back.
We are there,
we are doing both back to back.
And I think that might create a little bit of a misconception that the movies
are very,
very different from one another.
The reason why we're blocking those two movies together to shoot his,
because the cast is so massive.
Yeah.
And there are so many different people involved in that movie.
It just became justically and financially sensible to block work for the actors
in that manner.
So that's,
that's sort of why the,
those movies are being approached that way.
Okay.
Well we'll lift up to the full one minute.
I just wanted to ask you about what you think about kind of digital mediums and
Netflix and youtube and do you see those environments to play with in particular
thinking youtube and kind of short,
tall,
short?
Well,
you know,
I think it's changing.
Yeah.
Changing
the business.
And I think if you're looking at,
um,
you know,
features,
uh,
um,
they're under a lot of pressure at the moment.
I think,
you know,
we've all understood storytelling,
uh,
f for the last hundred years in film as being a two hour closed ended experience
in the 80s that we introduce equalization,
uh,
with movies like star wars and jaws and the advent of the blockbuster.
Uh,
and I think it's getting more and more difficult to lure people out of their
homes because one,
the content is better.
Uh,
you know,
now that TV has been freed from the shackles of the Nielsen ratings.
A,
you're not trying to,
uh,
appeal to advertisers.
You're trying to appeal to the audience and the audience can be incredibly niche
as long as the,
you know,
when you have cash rich companies like Netflix and Amazon,
uh,
um,
because valuations are,
you know,
many times that have studios,
uh,
um,
you know,
their,
their only agenda is a cultural conversation.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
that there is no metric really,
uh,
for,
to gauge success,
which radically changes what you can do in terms of content.
As long as that content is provoked,
you know,
provokes a conversation,
uh,
it's successful.
Um,
and you know,
features,
you know,
if you,
if you need to go see a movie,
and I think this is why you're seeing it was massive branded films is to go see
movies.
Now it costs a lot of money.
You're going to spend a hundred pounds,
you know,
at the drop of a hat,
you gotta get a babysitter,
uh,
you know,
two of you go out to the theater,
a dinner popcorn.
This is a,
this is a very expensive event,
uh,
that is trying to compete with the media in your home.
And,
um,
and I think technology is going to change,
uh,
the way that we perceive content much faster than it changed over the last
hundred years very quickly.
And I think as I've got four kids myself,
we're all,
Eh,
you know,
age from 19 to 10.
So I've got a spread in the demographic,
uh,
and just watching their viewing habits and,
and you know,
I mean they're a majority of the content that they view is either on youtube or
on vine.
So their,
their sense of narrative as much shorter than my sense of narrative and their
ability to absorb content is much more significant than my ability to absorb
content.
So I think that is going to radically alter,
um,
uh,
how we tell stories moving,
moving forward.
And I think VR is going to blow everything wide open,
uh,
in the next 10 years because I think that is an experience that a is next level.
Uh,
and uh,
and,
and again may alter,
um,
uh,
storytelling moving forward.
If you have any questions,
I've lots of questions putting it all right.
If I give you,
do you wanna start here?
One of the fortunate people has she seen the movie and it's fantastic.
Best one I've seen so far.
I just want to ask a quick question in terms of the movie itself,
um,
all those civil war,
do you ever find that as,
as brothers with Dominic?
Did you guys have a confrontation between yourselves?
We're directly to the direction that you want to go at one point when,
when shooting
and we look,
we've been working together for a long time and are directing processes evolved
over many years.
I mean,
we have a very,
uh,
you know,
we,
I think maybe every directing team does it differently.
Just the,
in the same manner that every director works differently from another director.
It's very much based on,
you know,
sort of like what's your personalities are and sort of how you think and how
you,
how you create a Joe.
And I just have like a nonstop dialogue between ourselves.
We kind of saw our way through what our vision is,
how we want to achieve it,
how we want to execute it,
how to surprise ourselves.
Um,
but we do.
Yes,
it,
it does often take the place of a,
you know,
take it,
you couldn't,
can't turn into arguments frequently as part of our process.
We're very comfortable with that part of our process.
I mean,
one time a director friend of ours was sitting behind us at the monitors were
where we work while we're directing.
And,
uh,
he said,
at the end of the day,
he was like,
man,
it was so weird sitting behind you guys because,
yeah,
you guys are you guys the conversation you have with one another.
It's like the same conversation that I have in my head with myself when I'm
directing myself.
But as you know,
I think any,
any creator,
any artists,
you know,
goes through a process of,
of second guessing what they're trying to do,
trying to figure out what they're trying to do,
uh,
liking what they're doing,
not liking what they're doing.
You know,
it's,
you know,
so we get to externalize that process between us and,
uh,
we saw through it that way.
Yeah.
See if it was a big fight between super rooms and there's a bigger fight to be a
university that's Marvin went to you universe.
So when they announced that there will be super warm and then there'll be Batman
versus superman and they're going to be in the same year.
And everyone was like,
well,
which better?
So my question is did you guys go watch Batman,
Superman and did it influence your decision during the move like daughter do
Batman versus Superman.
That should be awesome.
We shouldn't make our move
any way.
Like how much influence do you want?
A huge,
I mean look,
we're film geeks so we weren't the kind of guys that grew up filmmakers playing
around with cameras.
We grew up film nerds,
like we grew up around this corner from a cinema tech and we geeked out on
foreign films and art house films and every kind of film.
That was sort of our thing.
So yes,
we are fans,
we've been fans are the of the con comic or in other genres,
but no,
I think that we might have a little bit of a disappointing answer for you in the
sense that,
look we,
we sort of developed our instincts about where we wanted to go on this story
telling this story.
Just thinking about where we were,
where we had taken the character in winter soldier,
where Captain America was.
There were specific narrative reasons that led us to civil war that we can go
into later.
But um,
the other thing is that we're not really aware,
you know?
Yes.
Bet You know that Batman versus superman was being developed,
but that's at another company.
There's no,
there's no overlap between these companies.
We basically have no idea what they're doing with the idea,
how they're shaping it,
how they're executing it.
They have no idea how we're shaping it,
you know,
there's just no connection between the two projects and I'm sure they were
following their instincts and what they thought they should do.
We were simply following our instincts in what we wanted to do.
We were very much thinking about how do we follow up winter soldier and what's
the right timing in the marvel cinematic universe for a story.
That's how we arrived at the issue of civil war.
We felt it was the right time.
We've watched these characters now at develop into a bit of a surrogate family
with one another over the course of several films and they have a very specific
purpose,
very specific abilities that bond them together.
And very thick relationships that they developed.
We felt it was time for a family fight and that's why we,
we gravitate to it,
the civil war.
So yeah.
So secret wars,
the book as well.
Right.
And it's a great book with no,
there are many movies like that,
like watchmen for example,
that they changed quite significantly the ending of the movie and stuff like
that.
So how much freedom,
freedom do you have changed the role of the book too?
Cause I guess menu of the viewers,
the audience will have read the book,
right?
Yeah.
We'll expect,
yeah.
Yeah.
We have the ultimate freedom to change whatever we want.
And I think,
I'm Dan,
I'm a comic book Fan.
I started collecting when I was 10 years old,
uh,
as a comic book fan.
I'm not particularly interested in going to the theater and seeing a literal
adaptation of a book.
And I'd read the book.
So,
you know,
and what,
what,
what manner or capacity?
I'm going to be surprised by the storytelling.
Uh,
we are working in the marvel cinematic universe,
uh,
which is not the publishing side of things.
Uh,
and,
uh,
a very different medium.
Uh,
we have two hours to tell stories.
They have,
you know,
months and months,
sometimes years,
multiple issues,
multiple,
uh,
writers,
you know,
offshoots,
crossovers.
Um,
so for us,
we just take the concept of the book,
uh,
especially in the civil war case.
We're taking the idea behind it,
which is that,
uh,
you know,
the,
that the Avengers need to be regulated by a government authority.
Uh,
but we take that idea and we apply it to where these characters are now in the
marvel cinematic universe so that we can exploit our storytelling.
Um,
so,
you know,
we definitely owe a debt to the book in that regard.
But,
um,
we're also very careful to not,
uh,
tell the story in a way that you're,
you know,
you could predict how do you read the book?
What's going to happen in the movie?
I love the word you should watch family.
I did feel like a family film.
I battles people clamoring for the crossovers with a TV show in the Netflix and
so forth.
But for me,
it didn't feel like that was the right place to happen.
It was just that those couches,
knowing each other and fighting felt like divine.
It's a surrogate family.
And yeah,
both Cap Antonio are patriarchal figures in very different ways,
you know,
uh,
and their,
their,
their personality types,
uh,
are that,
you know,
there's a,
there's a polarity.
Um,
um,
cap is a,
uh,
you know,
it really morally centered,
uh,
um,
strong,
uh,
individual who,
you know,
you could say his flaws that he's stubborn to a fault.
Uh,
and a,
and Tony is,
um,
you know,
is this a warring,
uh,
you know,
inside him as a war going on between his narcissism man is a desire to help
humanity and do good.
Um,
uh,
so I think,
you know,
with what was interesting about civil war was both characters that get
alternately been illustrated as patriarchal and this family called the Avengers.
And what would happen if these,
uh,
these two patriarchal figures,
you got mad at each other and uh,
and chose different sides on a very critical issue that was threatening to push
the family apart.
And that's really what the movie's about.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So I'm going to assume,
I'm going to ask what's it look like cause we need come into it.
You know,
he's like the big data is new.
So does he have any kind of,
just pulled you aside and say when should you do this?
The best way to describe it is I just like to tell our,
our first experience with Stanley.
So we're shooting the winter soldier and we're getting ready to,
uh,
you know,
we're going to,
it's the day where we're going to shoot his,
see his cameo scene,
which is,
I don't know if you remember,
you saw that movie.
He's working as a night watchman at the Smithsonian Museum in Washington DC when
someone breaks in,
in the middle of the night and steals caps,
World War II uniform this there.
And so,
you know,
we come in and he's a,
so we set the scene up.
It's very simple shot.
It's just him walking through the museum with a flashlight.
He notices the missing thing and he has a funny line.
So we've never met him before.
Uh,
he's coming from orange,
Cleveland shooting.
He's coming in from the airport and all of a sudden it's very important that
everything be ready to go the second he walks on set.
So he,
we,
we get the shot set up.
We knew,
we know.
Everyone knows what they're doing.
He walks on set.
He's like,
how you doing?
How you doing?
And he shakes everybody's hands real quick talking.
Boom.
He gets right on the mark.
We call action.
He walks to the scene about three or four or five times.
We've got it.
Okay.
I see you have,
I got to go.
Bye Bye.
Hey,
you guys are fantastic.
Bob.
I think go boom.
He's gone.
That stay on that.
That's it.
That's pretty much the experience of standing.
Yeah.
Putting a question at the back.
With the soldier,
which,
uh,
super successful,
so much that,
uh,
on this very,
those actions,
they had no qualms with it whatsoever.
Precedent.
No.
How was,
how was building up to that and do an author on other Captain America thing?
How would the pressure on that?
Well,
it's interesting.
You
look,
there's certainly can be a lot of pressure if you allow it.
Uh,
because the fan base is quite large,
quite passionate and very vocal.
Uh,
but they also speak with really disparate voices and everybody wants something
different from the movies.
Um,
so if you try to listen to the public,
you're gonna wind up making a mess of a film.
Uh,
we learned very early on in our careers that we always did our best work when we
were trying to make work that please us.
And then we would hope that,
uh,
everybody else,
um,
enjoyed,
enjoyed it as well.
Uh,
and we always said our worst work when you try to anticipate what the audience
wanted.
Um,
and also you just,
when you do that,
you don't sleep as well at night.
So,
um,
you know,
with a movie like this,
I think because there are two of us with a very zen approach to the filmmaking,
which is looking at,
you know,
uh,
we've been hired to do this job,
you know,
we're going to go out there and make a movie that we're proud of and we're happy
with.
And this was not an easy movie to make.
A from a,
um,
uh,
you know,
um,
it was a complicated film.
There's a,
it's very subversive and tone.
The third act is,
um,
unpredictable and,
uh,
and as you know,
very dark elements to it,
uh,
and,
created a,
uh,
a real fight inside marvel.
So this was from willing the movie into existence,
willing Robert into the film,
Willing Spiderman in the movie.
It was Herculean and scale.
But ultimately those were the things that we wanted to tell the story that we
wanted to tell a and a and,
and we knew that,
you know,
um,
just from a,
uh,
you know,
personal integrity standpoint that if we fought to win those things and we won
a,
that when the movie came out that,
you know,
again,
we would just feel better about the work that we did and sleep better at night.
So that's ultimately our goal is to just please ourselves.
And You keep your fingers crossed that the translates to an audience
for hair.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I've seen a lot of gag reels from the movies and it seems like they're all,
they all like to goof around and have fun wanting to know how hard it is to work
with them when they like to mess around that much.
It didn't feel like kindergarten or anything.
Every time you see one of those gag reels,
like art editor just showed us the one we're going to use for the DVD.
It's like I'm always surprised like I'm like my God,
there's so vulgarity lady Frasee and every other gag involves Anthony Mackie.
I mean,
look,
it's very interesting.
There are a number of what you know,
Joe and I worked in comedy for years,
so we like to create a set,
we love improvisational performers.
We like to create an environment on set where people feel very open to express
themselves and to be experimental and to be be surprising and it,
but also feel well supported and well connected to everybody else.
It's the environment we try to create among our crew as well.
We really love,
like Joe was saying earlier,
we love the pro process of collaboration,
so we try to create like a family like environment on set where everybody feels
very welcome and invited to contribute in every way they can.
That's it.
That's what we feed off of,
but yeah,
some,
you know,
some actors have very different processes.
Some people like to be a very focused and quiet and they sort of like our,
that Chadwick Bozeman for instance,
is very much like that.
He's a very,
very much a method actor.
He plays Black Panther in this movie.
Um,
he,
you know,
he's,
he's an American actor,
but he did a very,
very specific African accent for the character.
And he would stay in accent,
uh,
the entire time we were shooting,
we'd never speak in his normal voice.
So here's a guy who's kind of keeping in character,
keeps pretty quiet,
you know,
between takes,
doesn't really socialize much pleasant,
you know,
friendly but,
but very quiet.
And then there's other people like Anthony Mackie,
like Joe was just talking about who,
you know,
the second Anthony Mackie gets on set,
it's like he's doing a standup routine for everybody involved in the,
in the production,
which is a very entertaining,
it really helps the energy flow.
But you have,
you know,
we have a wide disparity of like how people like to work and Joe and I,
again,
as directors,
you try to create an environment where everybody feels comfortable and welcome
to work in the way they,
they can.
Sometimes it's hard to balance,
but I think over time we've developed a sense of how to keep things balanced.
So if you've got time for one more question,
so someone's got the mic over here
or
over here.
Yes sir.
Um,
I guess we're very passionate about technology and sometimes older than
passionate of,
and I'm guessing,
um,
you might have 30 on zero views,
a certain tag.
How do you kind of resolve conflict?
Some more buffaloes?
Yeah.
Um,
you know what,
it's really a
okay.
It's really just,
we just argued the concept out.
Uh,
and whoever has the better argument wins.
Um,
it's usually that's I think how we try to,
you talked about honors trailers earlier,
how we try to logic proof the work that we're doing
is we argue through every story point now,
you know,
different movies at different requirements.
So,
you know,
a winter soldier is a political thriller,
which the plot based film.
Uh,
the concept behind political thriller is that the lead character is,
uh,
is,
not caught up with the events that are actually occurring in the storytelling
there behind the events.
Uh,
and typically by the end of the second act,
they catch up with the plot of the movie,
uh,
at which point they can then engage the villain and the feet development of
third act,
civil war is very different because it's a,
it's a psychological thriller,
a that turns on the character choices that the characters make.
Uh,
and it's all leading towards a very cathartic,
uh,
a moment.
Um,
uh,
so,
you know,
for us it's uh,
uh,
the priorities are different.
Like in,
in,
uh,
winter soldier plot is a priority.
So all the work that we put into arguing about our,
our,
our process had to do with the plot and,
and trying to airtight the plot as much as possible.
A civil war is character driven and the choice,
you know,
the choices and the,
the,
the moments in the movie turning on character.
So a lot of our time and energy spent arguing about the characters and the
choices that they're making.
And do we have fidelity of the characters?
Is there a proper motivation for the characters in Franklin?
This movie plot is a secondary,
a secondary issue?
Yeah,
I think I'm also,
you know,
I think there's a lot of different types of directing teams and but there it is
striking how there seems to be a an uncommonly high percentage of them that are
siblings,
right among directing teams.
And I think that,
you know,
there,
there is a uniqueness in that relationship and that you do get to difficult
parts in the process where you have a difference of opinion and it's not
something you can necessarily logic through or are arrive at some sort of
objective answer.
It just boils down to like who is more passionate about their point of view at
that given moment.
If you have to choose go down road a or road B.
And I think that,
you know,
maybe with siblings you have,
you have that ability to like submit your ego at times because you have that
conditioning of growing up in a family together where you had to operate as a
unit,
you know,
for part of your life.
So you have that default you can go back to,
and I think it helps in the creative process to,
to give us a flexibility with one another perhaps.
No.
Okay.
Well,
thank you so much for joining us today.
You're going to go ready for the premiere?
That's right.
Yes,
we are.
Yeah.
Great.
Excited.
Uh,
so please join me in a massive applause.
[inaudible].